>>> CHINA MAKING VERY CLEAR
TODAY ITS ANGER AT THE UNITED
STATES AND ESPECIALLY AT NANCY
PELOSI.
THE HOUSE SPEAKER IS NOW IN
SOUTH KOREA AFTER WRAPPING UP A
DEFIANT VISIT TO TAIWAN EARLIER
TODAY.
JUST VISITING MADE CHINA
FURIOUS, BUT SPEAKER PELOSI DID
MORE THAN JUST HOLD PHOTO
OPPORTUNITIES.
SHE SPOKE WHEN VISITING TAIWAN'S
PARLIAMENT, AND SHE SPOKE AGAIN
WHEN MEETING WITH ITS PRESIDENT.
>> TODAY OUR DELEGATION WHICH
I'M VERY PROUD, CAME TO TAIWAN
TO MAKE UNEQUIVOCALLY CLEAR
WE'LL NOT ABANDON OUR COMMITMENT
TO TAIWAN AND WE'RE PROUDF OUR
ENDURING FRIENDSHIP.
>> CHINA IMMEDIATELY SENDING A
MESSAGE THAT FRIENDSHIP HAS ITS
PRICE.
LET'S GET STRAIGHT TO BEIJING,
LIVE NOW WITH CNN'S SALINA WANG.
>> CHINA'S RETALIATION IS JUST
GETTING STARTED.
IT FLEW DOZENS OF WAR PLANES
AROUND THE ISLAND AND ALSO
LAUNCHING A SERIES OF MILITARY
DRILLS AROUND THE ISLAND.
BEIJING EVEN RELEASED A MAP OF
THE MILITARY DRILLS AND IF YOU
LOOK AT IT, IT LITERALLY
ENCIRCLED THE ISLAND AND THE MAP
INDICATES SOME OF THOSE COULD
ENCROACH ON THE TERRITORIAL
WATERS.
THAT MEANS IT'S 14 MILES OF
TAIWAN'S SHORE.
TAIWAN IS CALLING THIS A
BLOCKADE THAT ENDANGERS REGIONAL
SECURITY.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS SAYING, LOOK,
THIS IS PRETTY MUCH WHAT WE
EXPECTED AND THEY'RE URGING
BEIJING NOT TO ESCALATE THE
TENSIONS.
WE'LL HAVE TO WATCH CLOSELY TO
SEE JUST HOW FAR BEIJING TAKES
THIS.
BECAUSE, YES, WE'RE AT A MOMENT
WHERE XI JINPING, CHINA'S LEADER
CANNOT LOOK WEAK, BUT HE ALSO
CANNOT AFFORD TO HAVE THIS
ESCALATE INTO A CRISIS.
WE HAVE TO REMEMBER WHEN WE SEE
THESE STRONG REACTIONS FROM
BEIJING IT'S DIRECTED TOWARDS
TAIWAN, YES, AND THE U.S., BUT
IT'S ALSO DIRECTED TO THE HOME
AUDIENCE.
THEY'RE TRYING TO PROVE TO THE
CHINESE PEOPLE THAT BEIJING IS
TAKING VERY SERIOUSLY WHAT THEY
SEE AS A NATIONAL HUMILIATION
BECAUSE THEY SEE TAIWAN AS A
RENEGADE PROVINCE THAT MUST BE
REUNIFIED WITH THE MAINLAND EVEN
BY FORCE IF NECESSARY.
>> THE FORMER DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE.
SALINA MAKES A KEY POINT THERE.
CHINA IS MAD.
THE UNITED STATES AND TAIWAN
KNOW THERE'S GOING TO BE A
RESPONSE.
WHERE'S THE LINE?
TAIWAN VIEWS WHAT'S HAPPENING
LIVE FIRE EXERCISES, THAT'S
UNACCEPTABLE BUT PREDICTABLE.
WHAT ARE YOU LOOKING FOR TO SEE
WHETHER THIS TURNS FROM A
LOWERCASE CRISIS INTO A CAPITAL
BOLD FACED CRISIS?
>> I THINK THERE ARE TWO THINGS.
ONE ARE THE ACTIVITIES AND THE
OTHER IS HOW LONG THIS LASTS.
SO THEY'RE PLANNING THESE
EXERCISES FOR ABOUT FOUR DAYS.
I THINK IT WILL GO INTO THE
TERRITORIAL WATERS.
WE'RE VERY CLOSE, AND MAYBE EVEN
MORE FLYOVERS OF THE MEDIAN
LINE, WHICH IS RATHER
UNPRECEDENTED.
IT'S REALLY ONLY HAPPENED ONCE
AT SCALE.
THE LAST TIME THERE WAS A MAJOR
HIGH LEVEL U.S. OFFICIAL DURING
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
AND WE COULD SEE A LOT MORE IN
TERMS OF CYBER, MAYBE MORE
ECONOMIC THINGS.
BUT HOPEFULLY IT WILL DIE DOWN.
ONE SCHOOL OF THOUGHT SAYS THAT,
AND ANOTHER SAYS THAT THIS IS
GOING TO BE THE FOURTH MAJOR
STRAIGHT CRISIS, THE LAST ONE
BEING THE CLINTON
ADMINISTRATION.
I'M KIND OF SOMEWHERE IN THE
MIDDLE MAYBE WE'RE GOING TO SEE
A LOT OF RATCHETING UP,
RATCHETING DOWN CONTINUING AND
CHINA IS GOING TO BE A LOT MORE
AGGRESSIVE.
>> IS IT A PAGE-TURNER, GAME
CHANGING INCIDENT SHE DIDN'T
HAVE TO SPEAK, SHE TWICE SPOKE
KNOWING HER REMARKS WOULD
INFURIATE CHINA.
AND BOTH TIMES SHE SPOKE SHE
SAID THIS WAS A TEST NOW BETWEEN
DICTATORSHIP AND DEMOCRACY.
WE'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO SAY
PUBLICLY THE UNITED STATES WOULD
STAND WITH TAIWAN IF BEIJING
WOULD TRY TO TAKE IT BY FORCE.
SHE WANTS TO CHANGE THAT
CLEARLY.
WILL IT HAPPEN?
>> AS ONE ANALYST I LIKE TO LOOK
AT SAYS THIS ISN'T AN EVENT,
THIS IS PROCESS.
AND I THINK THAT THIS PROCESS OF
OUR RELATIONSHIP HAS BEEN
TILTING.
IT HAS BEEN SLOWLY TURNING, AND
I THINK IT IS, AND FROM HERE I
THINK THIS IS AN INFLECTION
POINT, AND WE ARE GOING TO SEE
THIS RELATIONSHIP.
I MEAN THERE ARE ROUGH WATERS
AHEAD NO MATTER WHAT LOOKING AT
ALL THE SCENARIOS.
DO ROUGH WATERS INCLUDE THE
POSSIBILITY OF WAR EITHER BY
DESIGN OR MISCALCULATION?
>> CERTAINLY THERE'S SOME ROOM
FOR MISCALCULATION AND EVERYBODY
IS WORRIED ABOUT THAT.
I THINK IN THIS INSTANCE WE ARE
BEING CAREFUL, THE LANGUAGE
COMING OUT OF THE WHITE HOUSE
CAREFUL SO THINGS CAN HAPPEN.
THERE'S THIS FRICTION THAT
ALWAYS TAKES PLACE BUT I THINK
THAT, YOU KNOW, THE REAL DANGER
IS WHEN IS XI GOING TO
MILITARILY ATTACK TAIWAN?
AND I THINK INCREASINGLY IN MY
MIND THAT'S AN INEVITABLY EVEN
IF IT'S NOT A NEAR TERM ONE.
THERE LET'S GET MORE FROM
WASHINGTON.
CNN WHITE HOUSE REPORTER
NATASHA BERTRAND IS STANDING BY
WITH THAT INFORMATION.
I JUST WANT TO BRING UP THIS
MAP WILL BE SEEING THE CHINESE
MILITARY DRILLS.
AND WE KNOW THAT THEY WILL BE
COMING VERY CLOSE TO TAIWANESE
VOTERS AS WELL.
IN THE NEXT 40 MILES OR, SO
NATASHA IS IT LIKELY THAT THE
U.S. IS GOING TO RESPOND, PUT
OUT A STATEMENT, SAY WHAT THEY
ARE WORRIED ABOUT WE?
?
WE KNEW THAT SHE JINPING WOULD
WANT TO RESPOND FORCEFULLY
AGAINST WHAT IS NOW BEING SHOWN
IN TERMS OF WHAT IS BEING DONE
IN THIS MAP AROUND TAIWAN.
>> THAT IS THE BIG QUESTION AT
THIS HOUR IS WHETHER THE U.S.
IS ACTUALLY GONNA RESPOND WITH
ITS OWN SHOW OF FORCE A
RESPONSE TO THESE LIVE FIRE
EXERCISES THAT CHINA IS
ENGAGING IN OFF THE COAST OF
TAIWAN.
NOW ALL INDICATIONS AT THIS
POINT ARE THAT THEY ARE NOT
GOING TO.
THE NATIONAL SECURITY COUNCIL
SPOKESPERSON, JOHN KIRBY, HE
CAME OUT THIS MORNING AND HE
SAID AND THAT THEY EXPECTED
THIS.
THEY EXPECTED CHINA TO RUN WITH
THIS PLAYBOOK, IT IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT THEY ARE
NECESSARILY SURPRISED BY.
AND THAT THEY ARE ESSENTIALLY
GOING TO WATCH HOW THIS ALL
PLAYS OUT.
SO, IN OTHER WORDS, IT DOES NOT
SEEM AS THOUGH THE U.S. IS
GOING TO ENGAGE IN A DIRECT
KIND OF CONFRONTATION WITH THE
CHINESE OR SOMETHING THAT CAN
POTENTIALLY SPOT OF CONTROL.
THAT IS NOT SOMETHING THAT THE
U.S. WANTS, AT THIS MOMENT.
HOWEVER, KIRBY DID SAY THAT THE
U.S. IS GOING TO CONTINUE TO
OPERATE IN THE AIR, AND IN THE
SEAS, AS I HAVE FOR MANY
DECADES.
AND THAT THE U.S. IS NOT GOING
TO CHANGE ITS BEHAVIOR AS A
RESULT OF THE CHINESE
PROVOCATIONS, HERE.
AT THE SAME TIME, KIRBY SAID
THAT THE U.S. IS NOT GOING TO
ENGAGE IN ITS OWN KIND OF
SABER-RATTLING IT IS NOT GONNA
TRY TO PROVOKE THE CHINESE IN
ANY WAY.
ESSENTIALLY, THE MESSAGE HERE,
IS THAT THEY ARE GOING TO WATCH
AND SEE HOW THIS PLAYS OUT.
AND OF COURSE, IF CHINA WERE TO
MAKE ANY KIND OF OVERLY
AGGRESSIVE MOVES DIRECTLY
AGAINST TAIWAN.
FOR EXAMPLE, KIND OF CROSSING
THE LINES OF THE U.S. PERHAPS
DID NOT ANTICIPATE, THEN IT
RESERVES THE RIGHT OF COURSE TO
DEFEND TAIWAN IN ANY WAY THAT
THE U.S. DEEMS NECESSARY.
THEY HAVE NOT OF COURSE TAKEN
THAT OFF THE TABLE, AND THE
PRESIDENT HAS SAID MANY TIMES
THAT IT IS THE UNITED STATES
RESPONSIBILITY TO DEFEND TAIWAN
IN THE EVENT OF A KIND OF, YOU
KNOW, I KIND OF MAJOR
AGGRESSION BY CHINA GET SILENT.
SO REMAINS TO BE SEEN HOW THE
U.S. IS GOING TO RESPOND TO
THIS.
THEY HAVE BEEN DISCUSSING
INTERNALLY WHAT THE POTENTIAL
OPTIONS ARE, HERE.
IF CHINA DOES GET ACROSS THE
LINE.
BUT AGAIN, THEY ARE NOT FEELING
ANY THIS ISN'T EXPECTED.
THEY HAVE SAID REPEATEDLY THAT
THEY ANTICIPATE THAT CHINA
WOULD RESPOND IN SOME TYPE OF
WAY OF GETTING ALL OF THE
ANNOUNCEMENTS SHE JINPING HAS
PUT OUT THERE AHEAD OF PELOSI
AND RIGHT NOW WE'RE GONNA SEE
HOW IT'S GONNA PLAY.
OUT >> IN A VERY STRONG
LANGUAGE BY THE CHINESE, IN THE
LAST FEW.
DAYS ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
REALLY STRUCK ME WAS, THE
MILITARY SAYING THAT WE WILL
BEAR THE ENEMY.
AND SELINA JUST REITERATED THE
FACT THAT, THIS ISN'T ACTUALLY
RETALIATION PERHAPS AGAINST
UNITED STATES PER SE BUT RATHER
ON TAIWAN.
HOW CONCERNED IS THE U.S. RIGHT
NOW THAT THERE COULD BE A
TARGET ON THE LINE, OR DO YOU
THINK THAT IS GOING TO BE
CONTAINED TO SHOW SORT OF
STRENGTH AROUND TAIWAN AND
SHOWING THE WORLD THAT THIS IS
SOVEREIGNTY, THIS IS WHAT THEY
THINK IN TERMS OF THE ONE CHINA
POLICY.
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE BEEN
HEARING IN TERMS OF RHETORIC
FROM SHE JINPING FOR QUITE SOME
TIME.
>> I THINK THAT THE MAIN
CONCERN THAT THE WHITE HOUSE
HAS RIGHT NOW IS THAT SOMETHING
ACCIDENTAL HAPPENED.
IT IS MORE SO THAN ANY KIND OF
POTENTIAL DIRECT CONFRONTATION
BETWEEN, FOR EXAMPLE, U.S.
FORCES ARE OPERATING IN THE
WESTERN PACIFIC, AND CHINESE
FORCES WHO ARE CONDUCTING THE
STRUGGLES.
BUT THEY ARE CONCERNED BY IS
SOME KIND OF MISCALCULATION
THAT SPRAWLS OUT OF CONTROL.
THAT IS SOMETHING THE JOHN
KIRBY, AGAIN THE NATIONAL
SECURITY COUNCIL SPOKESMAN, HAS
MADE VERY CLEAR IN RECENT DAYS.
THAT BECAUSE THE CHINESE AND
HIS ESTIMATION DON'T REALLY
SEEM TO BE THINKING
STRATEGICALLY HERE, AND SEEM TO
BE REACTING KIND OF EMOTIONALLY
TO THIS VISIT BY PELOSI, THAT
SOMETHING WHO GO TOTALLY WRONG
AND CHINA CAN WAS CALCULATE.
THE U.S. OF COURSE, THEY HAVE
SAID THAT THEY DO ANTICIPATE
THAT THIS COULD GO ON FOR QUITE
AWHILE.
IF YOU GO ON OVER THE HORIZON,
AS KIRBY SAID, RECENTLY.
AND THAT THEY EXPECT CHINA TO
NOT JUST DROP THIS ANYTIME
SOON.
BECAUSE THEY VIEW THE STRUCK BY
PELOSI AS A MAJOR PROVOCATION.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, THERE IS
ALSO AN UNDERSTANDING HERE IN
THE U.S. THAT CHINA'S PRESIDENT
IS IN THIS EARLY WANT HUGE
ESCALATION IN COMPETITION WITH
THE UNITED STATES RIGHT NOW.
AND THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
AGAIN, IF THEY CROSS THAT LINE,
THEY CAN VERY WELL GET,
ELAINE.
>> ALL RIGHT, NATASHA
BERTRAND GOOD TO SEE YOU.
THANKYOU.